Studies show that global sugar consumption has risen dramatically...
...from 11 million tons in 1900, to about 145 million tons today.
Analysts attribute the growth to population increases and greater wealth.
What used to be a rare food additive is now a staple.
High fructose corn syrup and other forms of sugar...
...are routinely added to processed food and many beverages.
The study included all added sugar,...
...even the sugar people add to their coffee.
While this may be good for the sugar industry,...
...it is not good for the heart.
Dr. Miriam Vos and public health nurse Jean Welsh at Emory University...
...collaborated in a study that shows eating a lot of sugar...
...can increase your cholesterol and triglycerides,...
...which make up body fat also known as lipids...
...and that increases the risk for heart disease.
Just like eating a high fat diet can increase your levels of triglycerides and cholesterol,...
...eating sugar can also affect those same lipids.
The researchers studied US government nutritional data...
...and fat levels in the blood...
...in more than 6,000 adults for at least six years.
The participants were divided into five groups...
...according to the amount of sugar and sugar-based sweeteners they consumed daily.